hey you guys flickers of fear time and
we're covering yet another dario argento
movie today this is a classic uh
probably i don't think anybody would
argue with me on this score probably one
of his best films probably not my i
don't think it's my favorite giallo of
his that would probably be deep red and
i don't think it's my overall favorite
film of his that would be suspiria but
this is definitely i think this is
probably my second favorite giallo of
his he made a lot of really good ones
this is tenebre now the interesting
thing about this look i have this
anchor bay dvd i can't remember what
year this came out it was probably like
early to mid 2000s
and this i see this on like a lot of um
on a lot of uh releases of it and it's
actually spelled like that like without
the a
uh which i guess is sort of correct also
but actually if you watch the movie um
the title of it is actually
b-r-a-e which is as far as i know the
more correct title uh yeah so that's
latin for shadows or darkness now
here's something that always kind of
like got me about this so as most people
know anything about italian horror no
suspiria came out in 1977
and that was the first of his so-called
three mothers trilogy uh you know kind
of supernatural when he had you know pr
previous to that been making mostly like
giallo movies which is kind of what he
was known for so suspiria came out in
1977 and was like a really big hit and
so then he decided he was gonna make the
second uh movie in the three mothers
trilogy which was inferno and that came
out in 1980 but apparently that wasn't a
real good experience for him i think um
there was a lot of studio meddling and
it didn't really come out the way he
wanted um we've done a review of it a
while back and it's a good movie but
obviously it's not
anything like uh suspiria like not
anything is good anywhere as good as
suspiria um and he was kind of
disappointed with it and it really
didn't do very well it kind of like
flopped you know what i mean
so after that he was just kind of like
you know what i'm just going to go back
to making jellos so interestingly even
though the the movie that he made that
would become tenebre which came out in
1982 at least in europe was called
tenebre and you could argue
that because one of the three mothers
from the trilogy was called mater
tenebrarum or mother of darkness mother
of shadows i maybe people thought that
it's like oh this is the third one but
that's not how it turned out um actually
he didn't make the third one until when
was it
2007 i want to say or you know it was
yeah it was like a long time uh mother
of tears and i didn't love it i'd have
to revisit it because i think i've only
seen it once or twice and that was like
a long time ago and i remember being
really disappointed in it but i'll
eventually get around to doing that one
as well
so actually tenebre is his return to the
giallo film now apparently he got the
idea for this um i guess he'd been
staying in la for a little while
and i guess he was kind of getting sort
of like upset by all this sort of like
random crime that was going on like in
la during this time period also on a
more personal note apparently according
to him um he sort of had this dude that
was like a stalker like when he was in
la and apparently this dude had become
obsessed with suspiria and it was like
really emotionally um
kind of like messing him up and he
started writing to dario argento like he
found out where he was uh living at the
time and he started writing to him and
calling him and daario said that at
first he was kind of like seemed normal
and they were just like talking about
the movie and how much the guy had uh
liked the movie and how you know how
much suspiria had affected him but he's
like as time went on the dude got
crazier and crazier and then basically
uh started sending him death threats
because he's like you made this movie
and it [ __ ] my emotions all up and so
i'm gonna get back at you
so
that experience uh went into his writing
of tenebre
and it's interesting because this movie
i think this is probably and i'm not the
only like person that says this i think
this is probably his most
i don't know if i'd call it
straightforward but i mean because a lot
of his movies and a lot of italian
horror in general is kind of
dreamlike um you know what i mean it
doesn't have like a lot of even some of
the giallo movies which are on their
face um crime thrillers uh have like a
lot of surrealist kind of uh things to
it and like narrative stuff that doesn't
make sense um that's kind of one of the
hallmarks of the genre but this one has
a couple weird things in it but this one
is actually like pretty narratively
straightforward and pretty easy to
follow i will say though
that uh i don't know if you guys know
but it didn't come out in the united
states until 1984
and it came out under a different title
it came out under the title unsane
nothing to do with the more recent film
of the same name which i reviewed a
while back and uh at least 10 minutes
had been cut out of it including all of
the violence because this is a pretty
violent movie even for dario argento uh
and some of the kind of like exposition
sort of scenes so i think when it came
out in the us originally as unsane
people saw and were like what the [ __ ]
is even happening in this movie because
it was like incoherent uh if you see the
uncut version which is generally the one
that's available now it's easy it's very
straightforward it's very easy to follow
particularly for a dario or gento movie
so i just thought that was really funny
also i should say too that it was when
when it was released in europe i think
they had some problems with it like a
little bit of the very very famous like
last murder scene which is like super
gory i think some of that was trimmed
like in italy i think he they had some
problems in germany like they had to cut
some stuff out and everything but
generally not that much was taken out
but in the uk
tenebrae became one of the notorious 39
movies that were known as video nasties
so you weren't really allowed to like
show it you really let us show it or
rent it or anything like that which is
weird because
i don't know it's it's violent yeah but
it just i kind of feel like it wasn't it
was almost kind of like lumped into this
thing with all the other video nasties
that were kind of these schlocky
sort of movies and tenebrae is not
schlocky uh not at all it's actually
really really well thought out um you
know probably i'm not saying that his
other movies aren't but i'm just saying
that it's uh and actually dario argento
has actually talked the most about uh
tenebre i think
and like what he was trying to do with
it like what the thematic thrust of it
was there's a lot of like stuff going on
in this one it's really really he really
like put a lot of thought into the look
of it now interestingly even though it's
called tenebre uh which means like i
said darkness or shadows or whatever
um this movie
is
really really
bright
and
it's weird because it's the same
cinematographer i think that worked on
suspiria and this is almost kind of like
the polar opposite of that as far as
like cinematography and like the look of
it goes because
what daario wanted to do and i don't
think this is actually all that apparent
when you're watching the movie but what
his thought was uh as to the look of
this movie was that he wanted it to be
set i mean it's set in rome and you know
it is referred to as rome but he said i
i wanted it to almost be like an
imaginary city or a city that was like
five years in the future
after
like some kind of big um you know
cataclysm had wiped out most of the
population so the people that are left
are kind of like wealthy
so what he tried to do was that even
though he shot almost all of it on
location in rome
was that
he didn't want
anything that was recognizably like old
like landmarks and stuff like that from
rome that you would normally see these
kind of like renaissance era buildings
and paintings and things like that he's
like i don't want anything like that
he's like i want it to look completely
modern and i want it to look like
complete like depopulated like there's
people in it but when he films it it
almost looks like he's there's like
these huge piazzas and like all these
big like kind of brutalist architecture
buildings like apartment buildings
everything's like sleek and white and
like ultra modern and there's not really
that many people around and that was
deliberate like he wanted that i'm not
really entirely sure why but that's kind
of the look that he wanted for it
so as i said even though the title of it
is literally
darkness
he wanted it to look super bright and
almost all of the murders take place in
bright like harsh daily either outside
like in the sunlight or inside in like
really really harsh bright uh you know
interior lighting so it's very very
white and it's like really it's a really
interesting uh artistic choice i guess
um because i think that the tener bray
the darkness that he was talking about
he wanted to i think that he what he was
trying to get at was that
he was trying to uh imply that the
darkness he was talking about was the
darkness like inside of people so he
very deliberately didn't want darkness
to be on the outside everything is like
super bright and there aren't hardly any
shadows i think there's only one murder
that takes place at night but most of it
is
set during the daytime
so the story that we have
concerns a an american author named
peter neal
and he is played by anthony franciosa
now he is uh in rome he's promoting his
latest novel he's like a crime writer
but he's promoting his latest novel
which is called tenebre
and there's little bits and pieces of
the novel like read throughout the movie
but it's kind of like all you get from
it is that the books are basically crime
thrillers they're very violent and at
some point
one of the women that is uh like one of
the journalists that's interviewing him
like at a press conference or whatever
uh is kind of like yelling at him about
how misogynist like all of his stuff is
and it's like all of these women in it
are you know they're they're just
victims or ciphers or whatever and he
gets kind of like upset about this and
that's kind of another theme uh in this
movie as well there's a lot of themes of
like uh quote unquote sexual aberrant
behavior there's a lot of themes of
doubling as in
you know kind of like the light and dark
side of people's personality or almost
kind of like every character in this has
another
double or another counterpart like in
another character of the movie and like
there's a couple shots in that which you
know kind of get into a minute because
there's kind of a couple famous shots
where uh where that's kind of like uh
put forward you know what i mean like
everybody like you know peter neal for
instance who's like the main character
his double sort of is the detective like
you know what i mean because the way
that they sort of interact with one
another they're kind of like two sides
of the same coin um and um and peter
neal almost kind of like takes over a
detective role as well
so yeah so he so he gets to rome a weird
thing happens like he's flying from new
york and he has like his uh travel bag
or whatever and he kind of leaves it
because he has to go get a phone call
from his ex-fiance jane who factors into
the plot later on and he comes back to
his bag and he finds it but then when he
gets to rome and opens it like it's all
[ __ ] up like all of his clothes have
been like torn and like things like
splashed on them so you're led to
believe that jane did that probably but
it's kind of like left a mystery
so the pretty much the minute that he
lands in rome and gets to the hotel that
he's going to be living in for the time
being
it's him and his uh assistant anne who's
played by daria nickelode who obviously
was in a lot of dario argento's movies
they were a couple at the time daria
nickelode also uh co-wrote spiria and
several of his other uh movies as well
like she was kind of his uh you know
collaborator
so she's in this too oh and fun fact i
actually didn't know this because i just
rewatched this again and i know that
that's not daria nicolet's real voice uh
that's you know she's dubbed obviously
like a lot of the uh actors in this are
no although not so many of them because
there are actually a lot of americans in
this one but yeah her voice in tenebre
was dubbed by teresa russell of all
people and i was just kind of like oh
that's weird i thought that voice
sounded familiar but yeah
so there's that too so so him and anne
as soon as they get to the hotel
uh detectives come are like already in
the room and they're like okay well this
uh girl who we've seen this scene happen
prior there was a girl who was like a
shoplifter she was kind of like a
chronic shoplifter so she'd been picked
up a lot of times but i guess she got
out of it a lot of times because she was
like super hot and she would steal
something and in the scene she was
actually stealing a copy of tena brave
like from a you know bookstore or
whatever and she got caught and then she
goes into the office of the manager or
whatever and basically like hey if you
let me go it's just a paperback book you
know and gives him her address like
implying hey let me off of the
shoplifting i'll give you some sexual
favors and he's just like okay fair
enough but yeah so she ends up going
back to her apartment and getting killed
now when she gets killed it's like with
a straight razor and the killer like
shoves pages
of tenebrae the novel into her mouth
so the police are wondering if there's
some kind of connection if there's some
you know uh if if peter neal the author
you know knows somebody in rome that
maybe has a grudge against him or has
some kind of like obsession or something
like that so they start kind of a
relationship and it should be noted too
that it's not just the fact that
you know pages from his book were like
stuffed into the victim's mouth but also
the killer has made kind of like a
little ransom note type of situation and
put it under the door of his hotel room
um and it has like a quote from one of
from one of his books from tenebrae but
like you know in cut up letters so
obviously this is a killer who has a
particular
uh obsession with peter neal and his
work and so the cops so he's kind of
been like working with the cops to try
to figure out like who this person is
now as i mentioned earlier there's kind
of a press conference
and where he's kind of taking questions
from a bunch of different uh you know
journalists now one of these journalists
is a young woman that he he obviously
knows um because you know they kind of
talk to each other like friends and
everything her name is tilda but she
kind of comes at him
a little bit sideways at this one it's
just kind of like you know why are your
books so misogynist like why do you hate
women so much um and you know he gets
kind of taken aback because he's like
you know you've known me for 10 years
i'm not a misogynist and you know but
she's kind of like making the argument
that all of your you know all of the
women your stories are all victims or
they're all ciphers and uh various
things of that nature so uh his agent
who's played by john saxon by the way
said yeah john saxon is in this too his
character's name is bulmer and he
basically says well okay let's let's not
have this fight right now it's like
we'll set up uh you know a one-on-one
interview
it's also notable that another guy that
is a journalist
that seems really like probably like
overly interested in peter neal's stuff
is this dude named cristiano bertie
now cristiano bertie is kind of like
he's um they do like a tv interview
later on and he seems very
conservative in the fact that he's like
well all your books are about like
sexual deviance and he talks about
you know this character is gay and stuff
and um at which point peter neal's like
yeah well the character's gay but that
doesn't mean anything like that doesn't
have anything to do with like what
happens in the story he just happens to
be and that's everything like that but
this cristiano is like has this really
kind of creepy like overwhelmingly like
overwhelming interest in his work and is
talking about how all of his books are
about some kind of like sexual
uh aberrant behavior
and almost kind of like uh the books are
like punishing that kind of behavior so
like i said that's another theme that
kind of runs throughout this uh book now
as the movie goes on as in many giallo
films
you get like a lot of people getting
killed tilda uh the journalist who
accused him of being a misogynist um
she's also she's actually a lesbian and
her uh lover whose name is marion i
think i wanted to say it was marta but i
think it's marion and marion is bisexual
and um so they have like this big
argument but then somebody breaks into
their house and hacks both of them to
death with a straight razor and while
they're getting killed you can hear this
voice kind of whispering about calling
them like filthy slimy perverts so
you're led to assume that the killer is
like punishing people that he sees as
sexual deviants you know what i mean i
think the reason that he killed the
first girl like the shoplifter was
because she was basically offering
sexual favors in exchange for getting
off with shoplifting so he saw her as
you know like promiscuous or like a
[ __ ] so
that seems to be the killer's motive is
that he's like going around killing
people that he deems
uh you know sexually deviant uh and need
to be punished so that's kind of what he
seems to be doing and like i said you
still have you have the thing with the
black gloves and all that kind of stuff
so it's a classic uh giallo in that
sense uh another victim who actually is
not portrayed as a sexual deviant but is
just kind of like got in was at the
wrong place at the wrong time was this
young girl named maria who she is the
daughter of the
of the landlord or the p or the um owner
of the building where peter neal is
staying while he's you know doing his
book tour in rome or whatever
um she actually accidentally stumbles
across
the house
of the i mean she has a fight with her
boyfriend and
he dumps her off the back of the
motorcycle like in the middle of nowhere
and she ends up at this house that is
she's quickly able to determine is the
murderer's house because of various like
articles and various things in there
so the killer actually catches up with
her
and uh she gets killed also so at this
point the cops are just kind of like
well
they're they're kind of asking peter
neal like can you like rack your brain
to figure out who this person might be
because you know this person has kept
you know sliding notes with uh quotes
from tenebre the book under peter neal's
door sort of like obviously this is
somebody with an obsession with an
obsession with you
so peter neal thinks back and he goes
you know that that guy that that i
interviewed for you know was on the tv
interview with that uh cristiano bertie
guy he seems like really interest super
interested in my work and i thought it
was a little bit weird like he came
across as a little bit creepy so um so
the cops are like yeah maybe there's
something to that um and you know
peter's like i you know i hate to accuse
the guy or anything like that but that's
really the only person i can think of
that's like super interested in my work
and that kind of creeped me out in a
little bit even though i've only talked
to him a couple of times so the cops
actually don't go there at first but
peter neal and his uh he also has
another assistant like while he's in
rome named johnny like a really younger
guy and they're like well we're gonna go
to his house and kind of like watch him
and see what the deal is now
interestingly this part of the movie
reminded me a lot of uh it's it's kind
of a similar setup to like bird with a
crystal plumage type of thing where
somebody sees something happen through a
window
and
dis like didn't get a good enough view
or is kind of like haunted by
um a detail that they can't remember and
that's basically what ends up happening
like gianni and peter neil get separated
and then uh while gianni is watching
cristiano bertie in the house like
through this big glass window he
actually sees somebody come into
bertie's house and split his head open
with an axe so he sees him die but he
doesn't really see the killer he doesn't
get a good look at his face or anything
like that um and he's like you know
obviously freaking out so he runs across
the yard and then he finds peter neal
who has been knocked unconscious by a
rock or something like that peter he's
like man i don't know what happened
somebody just like came and [ __ ]
knocked me over or whatever and he's
like man cristiano bertie just got uh
killed like somebody got him in the face
with an axe and i didn't really see what
had happened now at this point the cops
are pretty sure
that the women were killed by cristiano
bertie and as that goes on too like
gianni who is as i said haunted by this
one detail that he couldn't quite
remember and he keeps replaying the
murder like over and over again in his
mind he finally remembers that the thing
that he
was struggling to remember that you know
that one detail was that whoever the
killer was like cristiano bertie was
like facing the killer and cristiano
bertie said i killed them i killed them
all
so they find out later on that cristiano
bertie was indeed the dude that killed
like all the women
prior to this time like with the uh
straight razor and that's indeed his uh
motive was that he thought they were all
perverts and he was punishing them
because he was like this crazy you know
uh so everybody is kind of like oh well
he was the killer and now he's dead but
obviously somebody killed him with an
axe and we're not really sure who that
is so
mystery's still out there but they're
kind everybody kind of feels better now
that bertie is dead cause they're like
well he for sure you know killed those
other women so we just have to figure
out who killed him now
so apparently there is still a killer
running around though because bulmer
played by john saxon
who up to now has been having
unbeknownst to peter neal has been
having an affair with his
ex-fiance jane although it's technically
it's not really an affair and i don't
know why they're worried about
him finding out about it because i mean
from everything that's going on in the
movie like i'm pretty sure that jane and
peter had broken up
and she was the one that was kind of
like obsessed with him apparently uh and
was kind and like followed him to rome
um but then you find out later i guess
she followed him to rome because she was
having an affair with john saxon or
whatever so i just i don't know it was
this whole thing but there kind of
seemed like they're worried about peter
neal finding out about it even though
apparently peter neal and jane have
broken up but whatever so they're trying
to be like all slick and on the dl and
everything and then so bulmer is like
okay well we're gonna meet for lunch at
this particular piazza and so he's there
so bulmer's there waiting in the square
and it's like the middle of the day and
there's like people around and all this
other kind of stuff but then somebody
basically walks up to him and he's like
hey whatever and then like the person
just like stabs him in the stomach and
then runs off now jane was coming to
meet bulmer but sees him dead laying
there and she like takes the [ __ ] off
now i should note too and i forgot to
mention this
but this is kind of like significant as
i said this is a pretty straightforward
narratively very very straightforward
film particularly for adario argento
film but there are a few weird
flashbacks and for a time you don't
actually know whose flashbacks these are
there's only like two or three of them
like kind of scattered through the thing
and they're always kind of you always
know when it's gonna happen because like
the music kind of changes like it goes
to this like weird like tinkly piano
kind of music and it kind of goes into
this weird like a beachy kind of scene
and what you have is you have
these three or four
boys and they're just like all in white
pants and no shirts and they're kind of
like they look like teenagers i guess
and it's on this beach somewhere
and then there's this woman like in a
white dress and these like red red red
pumps like shiny red pumps
and she's on a beach and she's kind of
um you know enticing them like putting
her you know uh putting you know one
sleeve of her dress down like showing
her boob and all this other stuff and
like all the um guys are like oh okay
we're all gonna get we're all gonna get
in on this and then another
boy who's dressed the same and you don't
see any of their faces it's kind of like
just shot from like the chest down so
you can see the woman but you can't see
any of the boys faces so then this other
boy comes and basically like smacks the
woman upside the head at which point uh
the other boys and the woman chase this
other boy down and like hold him down
and she starts like kicking him in the
[ __ ] crotch with her with her red
shoes and then putting her uh the heel
of her red shoe like in his mouth so
it's almost kind of like an oral rape
kind of thing and like i said this um
this movie is probably
you know a lot of his movies have sex
and nudity and stuff like that but this
probably has more uh i think this really
has more than any of his other ones not
only is this most his most violent one
as in the killings are more violent and
there are more of them but there's also
a lot of eroticism in this one which
some of his other ones have that too but
i kind of feel like this is sort of like
the peak of that so as i said this this
was is obviously a flashback this
happened to somebody um but we're not
sure who it who it is like until the end
so after bulmer is killed uh the cops
are just kind of like okay well now
obviously there's still a killer running
around but it can't be cristiano bertie
even though he for sure killed the first
victims so what the [ __ ] there's like
two killers right and then so bulmer
gets killed in just in the middle of the
day and then jane peter neal's ex-wife
or ex-fiance or whatever she is
ex-girlfriend she's kind of freaking out
because she just obviously saw her lover
get killed she goes back to her
apartment and in probably the most
famous scene of the movie she gets
really [ __ ] up i mean this i kind of
love this is the scene that um actually
got censored the most in this one
because basically she's kind of sitting
she has a gun and she's like sitting at
the table like freaking out because she
thinks somebody's gonna come after her
and uh somebody busts in the window and
with an axe and essentially like cuts
her arm off like at the forearm just on
the table just like cuts it off where
the gun is and she just like gets up and
then her arm is just kind of like
spraying blood just all over the [ __ ]
wall and it's just that that's why i
think that's why maybe he wanted like
everything on the sets to be white like
all the walls are white her dress is
white um you know she has like really
black hair and like really black
sunglasses but everything else is just
white so this just beautiful like
arterial spray
bright red blood glucose just [ __ ]
spraying all over the place and she's
sitting there with [ __ ] and then so
then like the guy comes in and like just
keeps hacking at her and hacking at her
and she's just uh there's just blood
everywhere i forgot to mention too that
gianni the little italian assistant the
young guy the one who couldn't remember
you know who just remembered that bertie
had said that i killed them all um he
actually as soon as he remembered that
basically somebody in the backseat of
the car like uh strangled him so it
wasn't so it's not just now everybody's
getting killed pretty much everybody
gets killed in this [ __ ] movie like
after the killer is done like hacking at
her they you know his feet come into the
shot and then they pan up
and then you discover spoiler alert
that peter neal is actually the killer
he wasn't the first killer that was
cristiano bertie but apparently what his
end game was
was that because
he got to rome and this nut case was
killing people because of his
books
he thought to himself well hey there's a
couple people that i'd like to rub out
so
why don't i just
why you know why don't why don't i just
like start killing people too i'll just
like take up the mantle uh so as soon as
you find out that peter neal was the one
killing people like after that point
like he actually killed cristiano bertie
then he killed gianni then he killed
bulmer and then he killed jane so he's
so that's there were two different
killers the first killer was using the
the straight razor and then the second
one was using the axe peter neal was
using the axe and then you'd discover
too that
the weird flashback sequences you've
seen with like the boys on the beach and
the you know the woman in the red shoes
those were actually his memories and
apparently what drove him to madness
again this is very very common in giallo
movies was some kind of like horrible
memory from childhood that like you know
made people made somebody insane and
that's why they you know started killing
people later on so apparently peter neal
was the kid who got the woman
kicking the [ __ ] out of his balls and
putting the foot putting the shoe in his
mouth and stuff like that and um
it's like this traumatic memory because
of sexual humiliation and he never got
over it interestingly too the woman in
this sequence is actually played by a
transgender uh woman eva robbins uh
who's been in i think this is probably
her best-known role but uh she was in
some other stuff as well and uh that was
uh deliberately that was
pretty sure that was done deliberately
although i don't know i don't know if
she was the originally cast for that but
she was cast later on
which made it a kind of interesting
dynamic because there's so much
and it was something i think like you
know transgender transsexualism you know
trans uh you know transvesticism was
something that he put like in a lot of
his other geology movies as well so he's
always been kind of interested
in
gender sort of stuff and uh so i think
that's kind of interesting that they
actually did cast a trans uh transgender
actress
to uh do this actual part it's not a
huge part uh there's no speaking lines
or anything like that but she's just
like uh you know on the beach and that's
kind of like peter neal's memory of that
happening so as i said that's that's
another kind of um you know
kind of thing about the the theme of
this being like you know quote unquote
sexual deviancy or or at least like how
people perceive things being sexual
deviant uh sexually deviant
so
uh basically at the end there's this big
uh confrontation and comes to the house
like the daria nickelodes character you
know peter neal's assistant and then
peter neal thinking like a woman comes
in the house and he thinks it's anne uh
and kills her with the axe but then it
turns out to actually be like the female
cop so ends up killing her and then ann
comes in and starts flipping out and
then the other cop comes in and
it looks like peter neal actually like
kills himself like he has a straight
razor just like uh cristiano bertie used
and he looks like he cuts his throat and
he lays there and they're like oh well
that's over but they go out to the car
to like call for backup or whatever and
then the cop
goes back into the house and sees that
the body's gone and so it turned out
that peter neal had actually faked his
death that was like a fake um you know a
fake razor and so he sneaks up behind
the cop and axes him to death also uh at
which point anne is like sitting out
there in the car going what the [ __ ] is
taking him so long in there and then
like so she comes in and it turns out
that there's like this sculpture like
this crazy modernist like silver
uh sculpture that's like all these
spikes and stuff and it's sort of like
falling against the door so that when
she opens the door because it's stuck
one of the spikes comes out and actually
ends up killing peter neal like kind of
like impaling him to the wall which i
think was an interesting choice because
another theme of this movie
is
kind of death by art i guess or
because one of the main tropes of the
movie is that the is that peter neal's
novels uh being violent are causing
someone to actually act out in violence
and dario argento um kind of got
accusations of that as well and i think
that's why he put like the whole scene
in there about how
about peter neal being accused of being
like a misogynist and you know you
having women as victims all the time and
just like hacking them up and so he was
kind of this movie is almost kind of
like a meta statement
about
violence and art and whether it can
cause violence in reality and i think it
kind of it's interesting too because
as it ends up like the first killer
cristiano bertie who
was apparently i mean he was nuts
obviously but he was inspired by
peter neal's novels to go out and start
killing people that he thought were
sexually deviant so he was like
punishing them but then it ends up that
the author himself the one that was
creating these fictional this fictional
violence actually crosses over into real
violence as well so it was almost so
like i said there's this whole like
duality type of thing where
where it's almost kind of like art
causing you know art uh creating life
and and vice versa like the line between
art and reality so i think that's like a
really interesting and i kind of pick up
more of that like every single time i
watch this movie because it's like a
fascinating there's so much like
going on in this movie you could have
like
you could write like a whole essays
about this which some people have
actually oh this is a great book if you
guys haven't uh read it it came out a
long time ago and it's kind of if you
know anything about dario argento or
italian uh you know cinema uh maitland
mcdonough she's uh kind of a she wrote a
biography of him and you know stuff like
that so there's um this is kind of
very uh in depth and goes into like all
of his movies and sort of like talks
about
the uh you know the the themes of them
and stuff like that but this is like
really really good if you're into dario
argento um so it came out like i said a
long time ago but anytime you see a
documentary about dario argento she's
going to be on it like talking about
she's kind of like one of the experts
about his movies and everything but yeah
so
this movie i think more than any other
ones is kind of like dario argento
not only you know did he have death
threats against him uh by somebody that
claimed that they had been driven insane
essentially by one of his movies
suspiria um so he put that into the
movie as well but he's also
putting stuff in there that you know uh
that critics had accused him of of
misogyny and things like that because of
his movies and wondering if
you know the violence in his movies
could manifest in reality so he's kind
of like making a liv i don't know if i'd
say he's making a statement about it but
it's just kind of he's exploring those
themes uh in in this movie which i think
is like actually uh quite cool but yeah
so as i said this came out in 82 easily
pr like i said probably my second
favorite jello of his uh deep red being
the first profundo russo if you prefer
um it's just
it it's just it seems so
well put together it's just very well
plotted um it's not slow at all it's not
you know and the look of it is like
really interesting the music too i guess
like for inferno he used keith emerson
normally he would use goblin obviously
uh but in 82 i believe goblin had broken
up
so and i think only the drummer had
legal rights to use the name goblin so
basically he just used like three of the
guys from goblin including like uh
claudio simonetti and some other and the
two other dudes and um so they're just
credited by their last names because he
couldn't use the name goblin but they
did um and i actually like quite like
the music for this one it's not my
favorite again but um i have like a cd
that has all of like goblin stuff on it
and uh this is definitely one of the
standouts again suspiria their music
versus spirit is my favorite but
this is uh definitely good also i can't
not i can't not talk about this one uh
shot because it's very famous even
though it doesn't really have much to do
with the movie
but there is a very famous shot in this
which i believe is two or three minutes
long
and it's a long crane shot that just
basically comes out of one apartment
window and like just tracks up the
entire
building like into another window and
then like finally finally at the end of
this very very long tracking shot is
kind of the killer like
busting open these uh blinds like to get
in the apartment and kill somebody it's
interesting too because you know the
score the music is going through this
whole thing so it's almost kind of like
this music and then you're just like
crawling up the side of this building
and it's so weird and then the music
which you think is on the soundtrack
uh there's one this is during the scene
where tilda the lesbian journalist and
her lover get killed so this goes on for
like two or three minutes and then tilda
suddenly goes turn that off and then her
girlfriend upstairs like takes the thing
off the record and the music stops so
it's like i don't know that like i said
it doesn't have a huge amount to do with
the rest of the movie but daario
insisted on doing this they used like a
what i think it's called a luma crane uh
i think that's how you pronounce it and
they had to get it from france it had
been used like in movies before but i
think this was the first time it had
been used in an italian movie and he was
just like really excited and so
everybody that talks about this movie
that knows stuff about film have to
bring up that really really long like
luma crane tracking shot just because
it's so
i don't know like i said it's
thematically does it have anything to do
with a movie other than maybe kind of
giving this sense of
oppression or of you know somebody being
on the outside because it's not
following the killer necessarily because
the killer's not like crawling all over
the building all the outside of the
building but it's just in there because
why not i mean
you know i kind of feel like dario
argento's whole filmmaking thing was
like it looks cool so [ __ ] it it doesn't
really matter even though this film like
i said is pretty thematically solid uh
and he obviously put a great deal of
thought into uh you know into the themes
of this and kind of exploring the themes
like i said even the stuff about duality
about um you know peter neal and the
detective being kind of like two sides
of the same coin there's also that other
great scene where the detective is like
standing there like looking down it's
like what at where peter neal's body was
like a few minutes before and then he
kind of ducks down and then peter neal
is like standing up there before him so
we're almost like replacing each other
so this really does seem to be like one
of the most well thought out like you
know and one of the most analytical
films i think that he ever made it has
like some kind of dreamlike stuff in it
but it is very very grounded in reality
and um it doesn't have a lot of the kind
of
dream like weird
you know uh nonsensical kind of stuff
even though the killings are over the
top uh as most killings in these types
of movies are but they're not you know
it's not weird like um you know i fell
into a room filled with barbed wire
weird you know what i mean where it's
just like it doesn't really make any
logical sense these pretty much they're
they're over the top and crazy but they
still make logical sense it's still like
grounded in reality but yeah so if
you've only seen
uh you know suspiria or whatever if you
haven't seen i mean this is definitely
um when he was still some people have
said that this was his last great uh
movie you know which
i i guess so because uh kind of by the
time i talked about um phenomena aka
creepers which i really actually kind of
like that movie but
i think that did kind of signal that was
the one that uh he did after this one a
kind of a decline in quality although i
will argue that opera was a pretty great
movie and i think that came out in 87 if
i'm remembering that correctly so he
still had some gas in the tank at this
point but
i probably would agree that tenebre was
like his last great movie i mean because
tenebree is a great movie um and the
ones after that were just like pretty
good to mediocre to terrible you know
what i mean i hate to say it but but
yeah so if you like jala movies in
general this is
pretty much i mean required viewing um
you know because it's easily one of the
best ones and one of the best dario
argento movies as well uh and if you've
only seen the american version which is
called unsane i don't even know if you
can if that's even available anymore but
even it's like don't even bother because
it is so chopped up uh
like i said at least 10 minutes of
footage are gone including all the
spectacular murders and a bunch of
exposition as well so it's like it makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever because
so much of it is missing um i'm pretty
sure that every
everything you can get of it nowadays is
you know the director's cut the way it
was supposed to be seen
so definitely check it out like i said i
have the dvd
from anchor bay which came in a long
time ago but it's pretty easy to get
i think that you can watch it on amazon
prime if you have a subscription and
probably some other streaming services
as well so if you've seen it and want to
talk about it in the comments then
please do so and i will see you guys on
the next flickers of fear
bye